you have a moment in this film that
required you to be naked and it's a
quick one but it's a funny moment
because your character is very much he
lives off the grid
he doesn't think nudity is an issue and
it's a really funny moment in the movie
where an older couple at a campground
fully clothed is walking by and you're
standing there buck naked with your
coffee and you're like it's a penis deal
with it you know and I was just curious
was that something the director made you
shoot over and over and over again I was
one quick shot now it was done fairly
quickly and it's probably a good thing
because it was a public campground and
it's not like an independent movie we
couldn't buy out the campground it was
there were people camping all around us
and so you shot a nude scene when
there's real people walking okay well
those two people that are walk in the
shot they hired to do it yes but there
were other people ya know in the
distance kind of going yeah and there's
a crow going
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're responsible for one of I I think
one of the most compelling fight scenes
of all time you did a terrific movie
called Eastern Promises and there is a
fight scene that takes place in a sauna
where you're not wearing any clothes and
it is the most harrowing fight scene and
if you're a guy you're watching it
because knives are involved but you're
in the most vulnerable state any man can
be in and it is terrifying but I that
was a less comfortable naked moment
that's for sure yeah that was exactly
you standing in a bus with a cup of
coffee saying it's a penis deal with it
not so bad
this it that looked like it was
incredibly brutal scene to shoot it was
but it was I mean David Cronenberg so
yeah kind of do whatever he says yeah
you do it he says take off your clothes
and fight two men with knives in a sauna
I know it wasn't in the script but just
today really he just sprung that one on
you okay will you go for it
you